if we all get to go in and have dat
level experiences somebody determines
how you go in and somebody manages
substrates that you enter and those are
the powerful people end of story
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake and we
are at the transformative technology
conference so many smart people so
grateful to be here
dan Vaghela is with us now from tech
emergence the founder I'm super excited
to talk to you man
pumped up really appreciate it so
alright we're before we talk about the
role of AI entering business and
government and how to best let that have
that happen before we get there who are
you how did you become who you are today
yeah even how did I get interested in
kind of the grand implications of AI in
some way so yeah all right ah it was a
little bit of a funky path so I began
with an interest in well-being so it
dawned on me at some point in my late
teens that things that are self-aware
have a weight on a moral scale and if
that's the case then you would want to
understand what what makes things what
what constitutes well-being what what
positive quality of versus negative
quality I'm not like a hardcore
utilitarian but there was a strength to
that was like oh that that would make
sense if you could improve that net
tonnage of happiness that would be
worthwhile and so undergrad and then
graduate school so I went to grad school
at UPenn under Martin Seligman for
positive psychology understand the
constituents of film fulfillment the
focus Allen was on skill acquisition so
I'm an MMA guy see oh my ears are all
messed up oh damn yeah so the way I paid
for Ivy League graduate school was
training fighters and doing a lot of
competitions so I you know got the black
belt you know did the national
tournaments and won some shiny stuff and
did did a lot of that jiu-jitsu stuff to
pay the bills you know undergrad and
graduate school cost money and my
friends were making Subway sandwiches
and selling insurance and I was like man
I'd rather teach people to choke each
other you know wouldn't that be more fun
so so I went in with a concentration not
just on the study of well-being but on
on what makes us learn faster so what
are the psychological models and and
what's kind of the neurological
happenings that constitute performance
in memory
performance and sport for me it was
combat sport performance in musical
instruments you know learning the violin
or performing the violin whatever the
case may be and while I was doing my
master's thesis there were russell's in
the breezes 2011 like hey man you know
you're doing like the neuro of like
learning you know the computer science
guys are doing learning but like with if
they could supposed to be kind of the
same thing so that people told me that
there's this rough analogy of how
they're doing computers now and so by
the time I got out of graduate school
the imagenet stuff with with machine
learning was just taking off so we're
seeing this human level performance in
these different tasks and I got at grad
school like man I'm might have studied
the wrong stuff so I sort of it dawned
on me that it's likely that through
cognitive enhancement through artificial
intelligence this net tonnage of
well-being rather than teaching people
and understanding the well-being
improvement of hominids that the
expansion of sentience itself through
non-biological means will will probably
be the the great moral crescendo the
most important thing so if right now
there's let's say two cups worth of
total qualia on earth if we could create
substrates like if we imagine what
crickets have for total quality a total
creative experience sensory experience
at imagination and then we imagine
people we see I don't know whatever a
million fold wise increase if there's
another one of those because you only
got a 3% genetic difference or five or
seven or whatever it is between chimps
and humans right but but you don't have
no spaceships with those chimps you know
I'm saying so if you take that up one
more step not even cricket to human
above you just go chimp to humans above
you go that one step that whatever that
is whether we enhance our way to it or
whether we in create create it raw
wouldn't that be the most kind of
important moral thing whatever is post
human whatever populates the galaxy with
raw qualia that shebang is sort of maybe
the only singular event the humanity
will be a part of that will will have a
ricochet morally for the universe so so
this dawned on me you know at at twenty
something right out of grad school and
that got me into AI yeah
I like it he's called it a moral
crescendo it's yeah you you're like yeah
chimp human what's next how do we get to
what snatch and why is it so important
to have the conversations with companies
and governments about how and I'll get
into that as well if you'd like to but
yeah that's part of the path and then
and then what as you started getting
interested in it what ended up getting
you to tech emergence yeah well I I was
24 so I started exploring this stuff at
the end of grad school was 22 23 and I
was like what do I do with this you know
my whole plan was well being in humans
and understanding that and proliferating
that now now that that may just sort of
not even not even hit the Richter scale
in the big picture here in terms of of
the the ultimate trajectory of
intelligence and sentience itself molded
over for a while at 24 I decided okay
well if if that was the big moral thing
then what do you what do you want to do
to make that event non-catastrophic what
are you gonna do you know I guess I
could write books I could do more TED
Talks stuff and you know cool but how do
you really want to contribute and I
think probably the what seemed most
evidence to me was what if there was a
way to encourage and better inform an
open minded interdisciplinary
conversation around what are we turning
ourselves into what what happens after
people because I think it's a non
provincial concern in other words kind
of like global warming it's like you
can't have just one group of humans
thinking about it I think as humanity we
may have to say hey guys um where we
going to take ourselves are we going to
play the upload game are we going to
allow ourselves to bow out when whatever
is beyond us emerges do we want to sort
of have some kind of a su scenario and
and there's a million ways that that
could go but if facilitating a well
informed conversation was the ball game
well wouldn't it make sense then to be a
hub to have the deepest insights on the
implications and applications of AI now
so that the hard capabilities of AI to
grasp the entire capability space in
healthcare in finance in defense and to
be able to make an open and frank sort
of layout of what's possible so that
folks like the World Bank who we do
research projects were just just
finished
one where or the UN that'll call on us
to give talks can talk governance so we
do the business with the business but at
the same time I think the grand
governance conversations have to involve
what can it do and so hey maybe that
conversation would be worth fostering
emanating applications and implications
yeah yeah you like that goodness and I
like how you gave all the different
disciplines right away as well health
care finance go defense then there's
there's so many more past that as well
yeah so yeah they're so they're calling
on you on the government side on the
business side and you are you creating
like a knowledge graph then yeah so
there's a whole bunch going on at
present so there's a there's a map of
best practices around to the adoption
and garnering of a return on artificial
intelligence I think for this technology
to proliferate people are gonna have to
understand what is the best practice for
you so we're actually in the middle of a
research project there and we're going
to be doing an in banking and pharma
kind of a total capability map in the
way that you're saying that'll be
updated every year to look at the level
of traction of the different
technologies the integration and cost
requirements to use those technologies
so ranking and scoring things in terms
of their capabilities and eventually
doing the same thing in defense right
now a lot of that is in building the an
ontology we already have the ontology
but mapping out the various companies
that offer solutions in that space but
really the the deeper research which is
talking to folks like Ben who's been
part of our previous polls Girt Celyn
and other folks like him back five six
years ago when I first got into this
then was maybe one of seven people that
cared you know about posting and
intelligence so - but we also talked to
the people in industry so yeah it's
going to be you know the ontology and
the startups is is what we do now really
tailored custom research for big
organizations and need to make expensive
decisions is a big bulk of what we do
now
but mapping that capability space over
time is I think the the purpose that we
could first pursue that that might again
foster which is you know what we plan to
do and inform kind of that global
conversation about where are we steering
it and right now maybe it's developing
drugs and saving lives and cool but in
the future I think it's going to be what
kind of brain ships do we allow in and
if they
doing it in Asia are we okay to do it
here and is there a way to ensure that
that there's an on arms race dynamic
going on so the transparency around the
tech is also to kind of you know maybe
let people put themselves on notice as
to what they think is morally
consequential and that we should maybe
think about regulating I don't think
we're nearly the big game there but
people actually care about the little
game and so we're part of that convo
until it gets to the next level honey
that's a really good way to put it is
that we're totally in the little game
right yes okay this is kiddie pool stuff
I just get to be honest I almost have to
pretend to be interested I mean like
I'll do it I do a good job at what I do
but at the end of the day like this is
important because it leads to the
crescendo like that yeah that's that's
why it's important is because
influencing the trajectory would be
important and right now it's just
getting on the radar which is still
important that it's baby steps and those
baby steps like you were describing
earlier they help with people's health
or deal stuff yep so you use in but like
as we get to as we get to the small game
versus big big game stuff I also want to
what you just said there was really cool
in your last part you said that that
there's a a ranking system that you do
and then like a linking system of nodes
like you connect yeah yeah I like that
you explain that sure so in terms of the
research that we deliver and and and the
stuff that we'll do regardless of
industry there's different facets and
factors to consider about a given
capability of AI so if we talk about the
capability think about a recent project
banking and customer service retail
banks have a lot of employees they have
a lot of revenue and they have a lot of
customers and being able to improve
customer service and reduce those costs
is a big deal for them and so if we look
at the capabilities of handling customer
inquiries we're not just talking about
email just abroad let's look at the
whole bubble um there will be different
technologies at different levels of
maturity so maybe there's software that
will purport to answer questions but
really for the bulk of applications is
more just about properly routing
incoming tickets to the right Department
and sorting but not necessarily being
capable of
responding all that much doing the deep
diving to know that that's the case is
something that a bank would want to know
before they spend money with a vendor
because everybody's going to brag that
they can get it all solved but our job
is to look within the different
capabilities face
space space spheres and say how much
traction do these applications have in
terms of ROI that they've actually
garnered with real companies what does
it take to integrate them what kinds of
data infrastructure do we need and
what's that going to cost to setup and
what kind of talent is going to be
required to run them and then similarly
how well are they getting picked up in
industry in general sometimes it will be
a technology that might not have that
much firm ROI but almost all the top
players are piloting it which means that
there may be more credence to that
application and more you know but
between fundraising and future traction
more promise for that in the near term
so being able to weigh those things it's
important before a bank goes and pulls
the trigger on you know let's hire these
people build out this department and
let's shoot for this goal to be possible
in two years it's like well do you want
to see what the companies can do first
yeah and most of them say yeah I guess
we would yeah and so that's that's the
business I like that a lot know who is
your team that is able to parse what an
AI company how much are wide there maybe
they get they actually have brought back
and what the data infrastructure
requirements are for these different
applications yeah so I have some AI
technical advisors a postdoc MIT guy by
the name of Marco loggy who's taught me
as much as much feeble Python as I'm
able to do but kind of got me got me the
fundamentals and got me through Andrew
and G's course but we have folks like
him and kind of a cadre of other people
who are of the academic PhD side and
then my team is is analysts so these are
people whose job it is to assess case
studies and to grill companies about
those case studies to get to the facts
and to determine what defensiveness from
a vendor implies if we're not getting
certain kinds of facts not able to find
them not able to get the proper response
during an interview on so so the core
squad is folks whose whole job is to
think through the lens of an executive
and ROI or or or the World Bank of the
you
and thinking about an end result not
thinking about the code but thinking
about an end result yeah and then the
PhD folks are the ones who would say
okay here's what we found and they'd say
well from a technical perspective I
think we should interpret this this way
this way or this way so so we've got the
the folks that can bring in like the the
hard math and the science but the core
team is just people who work through our
frameworks to assess these things purely
for a business but executives so both
parts are important in a research
product a very expensive research
product both parts are always in play
but the core team is is analyst in the
language we speak to the c-suite is is
not Python the language we speak is is
money yeah yeah interesting I
I'm I'm envisioning that like quite but
as the analysts are trying to find the
data so that you can actually have I'm
matching this process is difficult like
you are saying that sometimes it's not
transparent and it's difficult to find
but this is extremely people will pay a
lot of money governments want to know
who they're going into better with so do
companies they want to who they're
getting married to it cetera and what
reasonable goals to like they want to
say we want to do we want to achieve
this it's like well if if it takes four
times longer than you would suspect or
it takes two times longer and eight
times more money like maybe you should
know that so yes that - yeah what the
abilities will be accessible within the
next two years um you might have ideas
in the c-suite but they might be really
bad ideas um when you assess the lay of
the land and the maturity of the the
vendors in the space so interesting now
out of the conversations that you've
been having with governments and
corporations can you give us some that
you found to be most fascinating so far
and whatever you can tell us yeah yeah
sure um so in terms of questions from
governments do you mean or like the most
fascinating conversations you've had or
examples of your analysis of like a
prominent AI company being a really good
fit for a company okay we're being a
really bad fit in some ways just to
teach us about kind of what the stories
are there a lot of the a lot of the the
conversations that I often will have the
most fun
we'll be companies that have raised a
lot of money like 50 or 100 million
dollars and we'll need our concern with
really growing and dominating a given
space whatever it is you know drug
development or I you know retail
security or something those
conversations are often fun because
these are people that that more than
understand the business and the tech
understand the business models around AI
and in this I'm not going to say this is
good or bad but when we talk to VCS we
see a lot of the same thing there is a
unspoken understanding that whoever owns
the data can just win can just win all
together and that that's the promise of
AI so you talk to enough VCS no one's
ever gonna say like we'd sure like to
build a monopoly right cuz that's super
uncouth like Silicon Valley's like I
really it's like a very you know like
politically that's not cool you know
like you're a you're Oscar so so so no
one's gonna say it but it's it's known
that there will be no general search
engine outside of Google unless they get
destroyed because because they have the
best product they get all the users they
get all the data their product continues
to be better there's no reason to use
anything other than Google the same
would be the case in lead scoring for
selling cars or the same would be the
case in data security in a certain
sector industry or the same would be the
case in on physical security
applications for offices and and and
business premises or things along these
lines that someone will garner enough of
a base of users tenaciously to to inform
their product to have their AI be so
much more capable than the competitors
that there's no reason to buy from
anyone else and so a lot of the
conversations around business models
sometimes we're told overtly sometimes
they're beating around the bush with the
smaller questions but it's cycling
around dominance data dominance at which
which would ultimately be kind of like
at least the capability to sort of play
the Monopoly game yeah I'm soso
companies and NBC's I think are really
adamant about this and seeing the
business model modes and kind of
approaches to how people are going to do
that like what does it look like to
acquire all the data what does it look
like to garner that data plume that lets
us completely win our are curious
kondou-san
if they're good or bad but they're
they're interesting to see how many
people are thinking about them it's more
than I think most people assume damn and
that leads right into the big-picture
stuff which is if we care so much about
data dominance and geopolitically like
you were saying earlier why would we
there's so much geopolitical pressure on
on on being the being the I'm the first
movers and the ones that have the most
data the most tech the mo the best
quality product and what that does is it
makes all the of the ethical
considerations and the moral
considerations take a backseat and so
that is obviously becoming a growing
concern there's no longitudinal tests on
so many things that are just going that
we're moving forth with so now how did
your even you're speaking the language
right there in these scenarios you're
having with the conversations you're
having that's again it's how do we top
data dominate so where do you where do
you see how do we how do we bring them
here all right a fix for great great
question that's that's a right now I
think most ethics and AI is SuperDuper
virtue signaling stuff I hope to be able
to write about this soon because I'm
revolted by a huge majority of it um but
I do think that it's exciting to see
there's some tracks and there are people
that legitimately care there's a lot of
like companies just whipping out a white
paper about it just like when green
became a thing as like I also am green
you know like it were there with it but
I think it will lead to something more
meaningful here's where I think it's
ultimately about so I think that among
the group among the highest powers in
terms of companies and in terms of
nations I foresee this could be totally
wrong by the way if we shake hands in 15
years you might be like mana member that
dump thing you said but I actually
suspect it's right that substrate
monopoly is is sort of the end game of
the highest level businesses that the
googles abide use of the world and the
the big countries I mean primarily US
and China maybe we could argue the EU I
you know other people can jump in on
that I'm not as optimistic with with
those folks in terms of kind of the the
big game but um big nations big
companies who owns the substrate that
houses the most powerful AI and that
houses human experience as we begin to
live more and more in virtual worlds I'm
talking like this right not like this
but like this when we work when we have
teachers that are virtual when we are
all of our entertainment exists in this
other place of a place that is better
than the world it's just better than
it's just more customized it's to our
needs
it's to our preferences it helps us work
it helps us play it helps us relate
helps us grow in our character when when
when we exist in the virtual world and
whoever owns the substrate that houses
those experiences and whoever owns the
substrate that houses the powerful AI
uhm wins so that's the game so the
pinnacle of the the kind of dominance
game on earth among the great powers now
the small powers will mostly try to chip
away and just like when the UN was
formed the little countries what are
they bickering about when the UN was
formed back in 46 or whatever mostly to
make sure the big countries don't
dominate everything so they're mostly
playing a game to try to get the equity
and the power away from the big guys and
play though I'm a little guy and I'm
good and get the power away from the big
folks but among the big folks um you
know the Google sub ID is the the u.s.
is the China whoever owns that substrate
will be as close to kind of deity level
as you can get and will certainly be in
the best position to sort of wield the
might of that trajectory we talked about
where they would prefer and so I think
that's a dynamic to in my opinion be
somewhat wary of and in probably
somewhat skeptical of but I think at
least aware of I would consider it to be
exceedingly naive to think that that
isn't the case it could be wrong but
that's that's you know you asked where
does that go this data dominance thing
it goes to the highest level of
dominance my good man it goes to
substrate monopoly which which is sort
of as close to deity as a an
organization could could become at least
on this this little this little rock
that we sit on I agree with you so
that's I feel very similarly the
Google's Baidu's US China that's that's
the type of stuff on the companies or on
the scale of governments the ones with
the most data zones are the most
powerful AI is the ones that control the
everything that we see do feel engaged
with and we're I made this funny I was
just on my fourth 10-day meditation
retreat and when I
back I had this like had this graph that
I'd made it was just that this the
better the more indistinguishable
virtual realities get the more will
spend time is virtual realities for sure
because we just get to design the world
that we live in it's gonna be the world
of atoms is just garbage I mean you know
the atoms that matter are the atoms that
are in the substrate so so people when
people can live in blissful purpose of
creative expansive modes outside of like
this nutty worlds about it like strapped
in in this regard or plugged in in that
regard however it is um they're going in
yet like you said when it's
indistinguishable or just then then then
we're going in and so the atoms that
matter I guess are us for now until we
upload um or if that's even possible I'm
not I'm not a hundred percent there but
really the atoms that matter the atoms
that how is what you were just talking
about those are the atoms that matter
that the bits world is going to be where
we where we hang yeah it's well where
power is so then so then do you is is
what would be the ideal ethical and
moral situation with that this is a a to
be continued I think but I will say I
think there is an import to simply
saying this might be the case this might
be the the highest field of power like
that the highest sort of domain in which
power is exerted and determined that
that this is one that maybe we should
look at and we should see whose
positioning how within that that lens
that at least that awareness I think
means something I'm in transparency on
who's doing what which is what we do not
from a policing standpoint but just from
a market research standpoint I think
it's also someway important so sort of
understanding that that's a dynamic and
hopefully having citizenry's um
consciously be a part of non arms race
dynamics I love that when you said that
earlier I forgot to highlight it non
arms race dynamics because everything in
from biotech to neuro tech to even the
AI is now an arms race dynamic and if we
can do the non arms race dynamic that
fantastic fingers crossed I maybe will
end on this I
I am I'm I'm optimistic that there's
probably some way around overtly
Armageddon ish circumstances otherwise I
just wouldn't even try yeah um but there
is that there is a notion that kind of
in nature things eat things and things
who live just live because they they
they collaborate when it makes sense but
then they compete as soon as it doesn't
make sense and the things that that
persist are the winners and that the
last words of Alexander who spend a lot
of time doing and conquering but not
that much time succession planning and
died pretty early on and on his deathbed
there's a lot of purported last words of
Alexander and who the hell knows but um
Plutarch attributes it thusly that they
said King to whom will we give the
kingdom yeah and and the last words of
Alexander before he died to to would do
we give the kingdom is what they asked
him to here's what he said here's what
he said though um purportedly he said
and there's different interpretations
purportedly he said to the strongest and
then died so I wonder I wonder is it
always the strongest and is there a way
for humans to be aware that that is our
nature that that viciousness really is I
think a part of biology itself not I'm
not even morally judging it I'm just
saying it is what it is can we grasp if
that's a thing and maybe in some way
steer around to collaboration yea or nay
I don't know or will will that
collaboration always just be a tool for
whatever group is that it'll be used for
strength yeah there has been a decent
amount of push for this whole equity of
the nine billion in some way so that it
can be a decentralized sort of ubiquity
and anything that you want can be just
manifested so that there doesn't have to
be a strongest of the kingdom that that
could be the best way to progress but
you know biology definitely says
otherwise over the last four billion
years so it's it's kind of nuts to to
distinguish we all get to go in and have
dat level experiences somebody
determines how you go in and somebody
manages substrates that you enter and
those are the powerful people end of
story yeah yeah yeah I I you know what's
really funny about this conversation is
that if you didn't have to go give a
talk right now I'm sure we could on
pack this in so much more eventually
we're where's tech emergence based
Austin I was actually here for two years
but 80% of my business is east coast in
Europe and so two airplanes to London
it's me or you know other places in
Europe is doing well well when when you
come back we'll sit down for part two
and we can unpack more of this for now I
love the idea of analyzing a is to be
able to help governments and companies
most effectively and I'm happy that
you're doing that thank you for joining
us on the show yeah of course great to
meet you terrific and such a pleasure
and I'm and guys give us your comments
below we'd love to hear from you thanks
for tuning in also go and manifest your
dreams into the world go and build the
future much love everyone we'll talk to
you soon